I'm ready for it
BPO TT bring it on yes Big Brother is
going over the top with a new all online
season I'm ready to meet 12 new crazy
houseguests PT sat down with those
houseguests before they moved in and
there are definitely some over-the-top
personalities are you scared about
anybody seeing anything I might be butt
naked barefoot put a sack over my penis
I have no ideas go glue I hope there's a
pair of sisters what's your game plan
going in so I don't want to tell anybody
I don't want anyone to know if they ask
I say denies she might ruin my game she
might not and if someone calls us out
we're gonna have to fess up and be open
about it
super fans of course this is my fifth
time applying I'd like to say that I'm
gonna channel the doctor will I'm gonna
channel the dengue sling I love Big
Brother it's a mental game and you have
to be very social to get far the game of
life is a little bit different than the
game of Big Brother and if you're not
willing to chop the head off the snake
you're gonna get bit by some players
that totally in it just for that cash
prize at the end I'm poor and I need to
win the money oh my god I've been
mentally spending the money
purple weeks oh I haven't even started
the show it's always said hey just stick
it out in the house with crazy people
gonna have months and I'll give you
$250,000 like who wouldn't do that
a few who are looking for love I do plan
on having a show man if someone in the
house is you know if it's just me I want
like a Jeff and Jordan ladies [ __ ] come
talk to me all the time then you have
the overall just leader of alpha male
kind of presence other guys aren't gonna
like that there's other alpha males in
this group and they like that girl it's
gonna start drama and at least one
player who doesn't really know the game
at all I didn't know it was really still
airing at this point